all right so yeah as is that I'm tom the
lead engineer at Raza and I want to give
you a short overview over conversation
at AI agent agents and had to build
clever chat pods and especially how to
get started with few data samples a few
conversations and a few just not a lot
of data to get started with I mean a lot
of moles out there but how do you get
started with early 100 training examples
so here's an example what we want to
achieve so the user says hi and then he
tells the bot I just moved and we assume
he wants to change his address right
with our company and he's providing the
Edwards Oxford Street 20 which is
unfortunately not a unique address so
one is in near Harvard University but
that is actually not the one the user
wanted to use right so he's actually
moved to London and what the bot did
here is it's recognised okay know so it
provided the wrong address use the
additional information from London
combine that with the previous
information to then suggest the correct
address right and as you can see here
this is our only a pretty simple
dialogue but there is so many different
paths through through their dialogue so
user can provide the complete address at
once you can provide the address and
multiple messages or provide a wrong
address all that stuff but the idea is
the conversation and I will dramatically
change how users interact with software
right so they define what happens next
they define how the workflow happens and
it's quite different to to a webpage
right so in the web page you design it
and the user needs to find the
information he's looking for and it's ad
he is describing his need and you can
provide by analyzing that message you
can provide him him wisdom with the
information he's looking for all right
and yet we created an open source
framework for that which is based on a
lot of open source tools
so there's SK learn Chara's for our
machine learning models tend to flow and
yeah check it out and get up it's
another
HQ Roseanna youth and I want to have a
look at the architecture and a different
part of the framework so the natural
language understanding as well as the
dialogue handling sees an example or
what's the what's the better like
tomorrow can be text or voice it comes
in through channels of Facebook or
whatever and the first poet is a natural
language understanding which analyzes
the message and extract structured
information right intend entities any
any information the user wants to convey
Ayano semantic analysis is done in that
part and then there's a dialogue
management which combines the knowledge
across multiple messages right and it
can collect through the information from
a back-end so in this example where we
have a weather API we would then after
we have all the information about the
place as a time the user wants to know
the weather for we can then query a
database get resolved and at the end
there's native language generations
after we know what we want to do and
what we want to convey back to the user
we need to somehow generate text or
speech that the user can then read and
get this information out of so in this
example would be our be sunny and twenty
degrees and a couple of alternatives
like API every day I am and Louise which
is just hosted solutions and the
difference we try to make it open source
so everyone can contribute and
customized for their needs
all right so first of all I want to have
a look at the natural language
understanding and do get to take a bit
deeper into internet topic so as I said
the goal is to get structured
information so we can see here's the
different messages about restaurants so
I'm looking for a place in north of town
and what we want to extract our entities
for example north central Chinese
Mexican stuff like that and the enter
the intent of the whole message so that
could look like that right so we've got
the text interned identities they're
pretty pretty simple but how does that
work um so if you started with few data
samples the question is how do
you process the data and the key is to
rely on pre train models as long as you
can and only for the pieces where you
cannot do that rely on simple models for
your domain and as you collect more and
more data and move to more and more
complex models to improve the
performance so the pipeline through the
intent classification is very simple
this vectorization right skip gram model
go to AK pre train model on one of the
large corporates like Wikipedia or News
Cobras and then do the intent
classification all right so it's pretty
pretty easy and backs are your friends
here right so when we start out with few
data samples we try to just average the
words right which works pretty well for
for small data sets and for simple
examples but as soon as you could
collect more data you can then move to
more advanced models like recurrent
neural networks feed-in the votes one
after another to actually keep track of
word or that you lose when you average
over the birds all right so this is the
idea right so message comes in bag of
words then we get our linear or SVM or
neural network or later recurrent neural
network and then the output is the
intent of the message so in our case
would be request better arms that's
pretty simple but what happens if there
are words in there that you don't know
right so that's a huge problem with farm
like this pre trained real directors and
chat interfaces because users tend to
like misspelled words or just use words
that don't exist or emojis and stuff
like that and usually they aren't part
of any any word vectors that are
pre-trained and a couple of different
solutions one that works quite well and
smaller data sets is to build like
character engrams right so you collect
the engrams that there are most
informative like using T of IDF and then
encode them one heart and embed them and
add them to the representation of the
vector that you extract it from your pre
trained model this response solution
another solution would be using Elysee
ends characterize GM's to any of them on
the data set
if you have more data down the road and
second part is the entity extraction
pipeline so Alice bad sentence what's
the weather like tomorrow we also want
to extract tomorrow as date because we
need that to query our API and here the
problem is a bit more difficult because
when you train our model we want to
train it not on all the possible words
for that date Fiat right so we don't
want to trade on today every day that
we've seen like years and months but
rather we want to have a look at the
part of speech tag and the structure of
the sentence to generalize the the
pattern we have seen in the sentence to
two other sentences that I didn't
require a training data set so what we
do is we take a nicer sentence we we
annotated with part of speech 2xv the
chanko to combine the different pieces
of the sentence that belong together
then we use named entity recognition for
example conditional random field do the
entity extraction and then we we got our
date which is tomorrow in that case yeah
I want to go to demo just to show how as
simple as what you can see here is just
defining a pipeline of processing
pipelines so message comes in and go
through different components machine
learning components so first of all
there's just an initialization so
loading word vectors and we got our
named entity recognition using a
conditional random field then we got a
pre trained natural pre trained model
from Spacey that's trained on persons
and locations and dates and stuff like
that we got a feature either here which
uses engrams and a sod route vectors
trained in on I think Wikipedia and then
we got our intent class very Spacey all
right so this is a training it's going
to be pretty fast because that what
takes most of the time is just loading
the vectors into memory it's a pretty
small data sets it has only 48 for
examples as you can see here so we go to
40 different samples in here for
distance I think in 10
so affirm goodbye greed and restaurant
search and we also got two different
entities which is cuisine and location
and as you can see it's good trained
pretty quick it's actually doing a grid
search over an SVM but as at just 40
samples
yeah it's let's try it out on that the
example which is not part of your
training data but as you can see even
though we only have a small data set
it's it's due to the simple sentences
that are usually used in chat messages
it's possible to rely on smaller data
sets and still be able to recognize
named entities like in this case we go
Mexican from our NER CRF and
the pre trained model are recognized
Potsdam s city so it's pre trained in
other cities and countries and stuff
like that and the restaurant search
alright cool
now when I have a look at the more
interesting for the lilac handling
because the natural language
understanding is pretty much so for
these simple messages and as long as you
collect more and more data you're fine
there but the dialogue handling is a bit
more involved so the user systems use
handcrafted routes so you define okay is
this is the message I've seen and this
is what I'm going to do next
but that gets pretty complicated even
for simpler examples as I shown you for
for the address case
so once the reason is to go data-driven
so here's an example that goes into a
bit in a bit of a different direction
but as you can see the Machine combines
the knowledge from from the message and
responds accordingly and that data is
collected and fed back into the machine
learning model to train it and refine it
yeah this this dialogue shown here is a
bit different from what we're actually
doing and what we want to actually
achieve because this is more of
philosophical and interest kind of
dialogue but we're actually looking for
goal-oriented dialogue so we actually
want to achieve something and solve a
problem for the user so how does the
dialogue handling look like so he's a
pretty simple
graphic how that works so we got our
message and instructor data out of that
message we combined it with the state
we've collected across all messages and
that calculates the next action so it's
pretty crazy and that can be an SVM of
current neural network depending on how
much data we have and that next action
then creates the output to the user so
in this case it will be sunny 20 degrees
and updates the internal state so that's
the whole idea
next message message comes in will use
the the internal state and predict the
next action so this is the whole flow
that all of these dialog systems use to
predict next actions but I want to have
a closer look at what the models look
like and how we generate the data that
goes in there so as I said first intent
classification using as we and then
entity extraction and then feeding that
data in into recurrent neural network so
we tried Alice EMS and directory pre
well even in small data sets overfitting
them pretty harshly right so this is the
first input for for our labs GM and the
other input our API calls the data we
gather from their sterilizing jars using
feature riser and entity output our
action generates and usually there's an
action mask because models tend to be
wrong and predict actions that aren't
correct and sometimes you want to
enforce like security regulations and
stuff like that and so you mask out a
couple of actions there if the
prediction is actually what you want and
looking for it and we normalize to get
probabilities again your sample from
that distribution during training and
predicting you just take the max and yet
depending on the action we now either do
an API call adding further information
to our loop and to a recurrent neural
network and basically we keep
predicting and B going to stay in that
loop until we we predict a special
action which is usually called listening
or something like that which just says
okay we're going to stop our loop and we
listen for the next message
from the user in this case our bot might
create like the response it will be
sunny and 20 degrees all right so this
is the idea that works here and in this
example we might do like three loops the
first one is user message comes in we go
to the API from the weather provider get
their data feed it in back into our lsdm
we see that API provided a result hence
the the yellow CM should predict Tecton
that the next action is okay feed that
information back to the user and then
the third prediction would be listen to
the next user input but hard to get
started right so how how do we generate
training data on usually when you create
like an assistant you don't have any
data so you might be able to create like
messages which is pretty easy so
collecting data about greetings goodbyes
and stuff like that and what's the
weather like tomorrow or how's the
better going to be but you still need
training data for the dialog and the
solution here is using online learning
oh it's one solution thought like the
final solution but as soon as the bot
does something stupid sigh how did you
like it
so which doesn't really make sense in
that context of the message from the
user we can assume in this example that
we understood the message correctly so
we got the correct intent and correctly
entities but the state is wrong right so
we'll predict the wrong next action and
what we do is we correct their behavior
and retrain a model so it's pretty
simple so labeling it directly and
adding data to the model again for the
lsdm that works for you pretty well
right and if we use the retrain model to
predict the next action which should
then be corrected and hopefully the
right hole okay
I'll show that as well
okay cool so what's happening is the
data is getting loaded and lsdm is
pre-trained so it's pre drained and
acting like 10 dialogues or something
like that and what happens now is the
script just loads user messages from a 5
so it's just a file of a couple of lines
of like random user messages so the user
is not actually responding to what the
bot is saying just providing random
answers which can't happen or realizes
also there should be good for really
example and what you can see here in
green is what the user said which is
just read so this already showing the
intent in the middle we can see the
slots or the state of the bot what what
internal information it has stored we
cannot see the representation of the
lsdm right because that in turn around
not really readable but we know which
information we feed in and now the bot
wants to do a search which which doesn't
really make sense because we don't have
any information yet about or do you that
wants to do so
you can't just correct that we didn't
really invest in a lot of UI here but
should show the principle so first we
want to do say hello
greet them so it should be - I think so
hey there yeah and then we want to ask
him how it can help which is five and
then you should live and so that was
correct predictions a good job there and
now the user provided us with location
roam and price cheap so this is what he
is looking for the restaurant is looking
for and we stored their information
internally and we're going to feed that
into the LCM now
and now the prediction was listen again
which is not a good idea and we can see
that the predictions already started
changing right and beginning there was
pretty uniform distribution and right
now we've got it spit stars changing and
moving towards the action I already used
what I want to do so yeah I need to
query the user for for the number of
people for the restaurant he's looking
for which is number seven
that we're gonna listen for the users
input right so the user now is providing
the de cuisine is going to be Spanish
which is not what I asked for but okay
because still going to store that and
the button now once you do ask numb
people again which is actually a good
idea but then we need to listen again
okay cool
right so now we got that information
about people six so that's that's good
now I think I think we got everything
sold so we had agree have a cusine a
price and allocation and so the next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to do this search and then we gonna
search and then we're gonna suggest that
okay so now the whole flow is finished
right so this addition is Papa's pizza
place from the bot and now the bottle is
finished and should listen to the next
user inputs and now the user starts
changing his his stuff again because it
just didn't listen what the what was
saying but it's okay so it's the normal
user behavior which would just as well
it could just change the query to a
different price in this case so now it
price it's expensive so yeah and that's
the whole idea as you can see again so
the probabilities can keep changing and
it should adjust to the flow I provided
to the table yeah yeah this is the whole
idea how to train a bot when when
getting started a few training examples
and what what you would then do is doing
your role are to just collect more and
more data about the dialogues and use
them for further training cool yeah yeah
it's a couple of final thoughts here so
there's still a lot of open up
challenges here so for example the
combination of different dialogue malls
so what I've just shown is one dialogue
model that is usually task oriented but
ideally what you also want to have a
chitchat more so users tend to ask
questions like how are you or what's
your favorite food or something like
that
colors as we come on over and you
actually want to reuse these train
models and that's that's a tough
challenge because you need to decide
when to use which model and when to
switch between walls and that's what
we're looking at in a moment then you
get your unsupervised multi-language
entity recognition so that should would
be ideal then annotate your entities in
one language and then transform your
board into a new language without a lot
of work by journaling pod and then those
dialogue generalizations of a couple of
patterns in dialogues that keep
repeating so this is for example if we
want to do this weather API call the
user needs to provide location and a
date but it doesn't really matter in
which order the user provides that and
this is like a common pattern for these
types of thoughts so no matter which
order the information is provided it
should work and yeah usually we want to
augment your training data sets to
account for that so you don't need to
specify it all at once beforehand right
yeah and so they do a couple good reads
out there and I think the video is going
to be published afterwards so you can
have a look at the links in today's last
rules which is computational linguistics
and deep learning which is blog posters
pretty good read there's memory networks
which is the base for most of the state
of the papers on that topic
it moved further down the line to
end-to-end networks now but they aren't
there yet especially for smaller data
sets so basically instead of having this
intermediate part of natural language
processing and intent classification you
directly feed in your character stream
into your dialogue management system
right so no pre classification there but
really enter and from message to action
by asset and holidays that it isn't
there yet we can't really use that yet
so that's left on the paper I referenced
here and then they use mem end-to-end in
Python which is a really good
visualization so go now look at that
it's quite cool product and open source
as well
yeah three thoughts to take her with arm
so they a lot of techniques to handle
small data sets and really the key is to
rely on three train models and what we
try to do and get started with
conversation and I Dec quickly and then
move on from your simpler models like
using an SVM for intent classification
and then move on to more complex models
like taking word order into account
using Alice TMS or other recurrent
neural networks right and these please
more advanced model three we tried it
out on the baby Facebook data set which
is like a restaurant search data set
used for performance measurement for
dialect systems and read these deep
techniques of recruit neural networks
helps to on the state of the other in
processing and predicting next actions
for for these assistants and we event in
flowcharts so that's not a good idea
even to get started with the bot will
quickly not know what it should do you
will not think of all the cases and you
just fall through your if and else
statements so data-driven dialogue
analysis is really the future here and
what we should aim for yeah that's about
it I'm so really get in touch there have
a look at the open source project we're
going to open SUSE the on dialogue
products but also to training and harder
how we use the algorithms there and yeah
check it out talk to me if you have any
questions afterwards and we actually
hiring so looking for data science
scientists machine learning engineers
and yeah
[Applause]
hi thanks a lot
one thing I was wondering because you
said don't use flow diagrams
yeah but how large is the weight of the
intent in determining the next action
isn't that the main driver of what the
next action will be yeah and in the
beginning really it is but when you tend
to do more complex dialogues like for
example let's imagine dental insurance
arrives user needs to provide a couple
of different information pieces of
information so his age and stuff like
that and you will have questions like is
that right as a valid ID which where the
intent is just affirmed or something
like that and then the intent itself
doesn't retell you much about the next
action but for these simple cases for
the restaurant search for example you're
completely right so if the user says I'm
looking for a restaurant then that most
certainly next action is searched for a
restaurant then it will resemble a flow
diagram basically yeah that's a pretty
simple example but that's what we do
with our lsdm and we've been retrain it
so we've overfit it to be like a flow
chart right so it's really looking for
the data we've seen ended in in the
training set and then as we collect more
data we then move over to to stop the
overfitting and to like make it more
generalizable that handles cases it
hasn't seen during training nice yeah I
was a bit confused I didn't really
understand how do you train the system
to recognize intent and and I mean
intent can also do something very broad
I imagine that you define it depending
on the domain of the bot so you mean how
we do the intent classification yeah for
right um so that should be that one the
one before so what we do is we take in
the message feature is each word using
virtual racks
then we usually append features that are
more reflecting out of scope words or
out of order for capillary words using
engrams using character LCMS create a
new word vector for
rude then combine these four simple
models just averaging them right bag of
words model and then putting them
through an Alice TM no not an ultimate
and SVM obviously but I mean there you
have like five different kinds of
intense I mean but I imagine there are
BOTS where you have if you want to go
through a booking of something really
important you yeah have can you check
you want to change something yeah those
things must be hard to the triangles
yeah so the system we work with arm so
are around like a hundred intense tends
to work pretty well store okay and and
you also do you have anything to
generate the training data automatically
we go to all the examples and you you
annotate yourself when went to get
training data so in the beginning we
really start just writing samples so the
first samples are just written by humans
then the next step is usually that we
like go I'm Amazon Turk and provide a
couple more training samples and then we
do like automate labeling and corrector
every thought about using active
learning this story have you thought
about using active learning now have you
didn't might be a good idea okay mmm
thanks
I hate this great talk
I wondered it looked like your dialogue
training through the dialogue and
training was using something that looks
like a reinforcement learning sort of
set up I mean it was that part of the
way the sort of structure that you were
implementing or how was it different
with me or maybe I didn't understand so
it was a bit hard to understand I didn't
give the microphone at the mouth so just
let me repeat and describe me if I'm
wrong are we using reinforcement
learning for the dialogue handling
I mean look like it looked like
reinforcement or no reinforcement
learning sort of formalism and I was
learning like that yeah - pardon you're
okay right so we've tried it out and
we're actually experimenting with that
with a couple of data sets but we
haven't like edited - the framework gap
but we're really thinking about it but
this is where you just online learning
so using the lsdm and then adding couple
more training examples training on it on
a through the batch like sampling in a
couple of more training examples from
the original data is that so that the LC
doesn't keep forgetting the original
training data and that basic used is an
online learning algorithm but we're
actually thinking about reinforcement
learning so cool
no other question from the audience I
ever won okay
what's your business model how do you as
organization or money with this right so
what we do is we try to open source all
the stuff we use for our dialog handling
and natural language processing and we
do produce larger corporates like you
yes heavies are insurance companies and
provide them with customized solutions
so really working on their problem
finding out of cables or custom solution
for them because they just really don't
know how they can use conversational
assistance and the second power really
is that would provide couple more tools
for enterprise like monitoring and stuff
like that but but really to is for
startups or Kirsten projects are there
and it can be used for and that's the
idea
great let's thank our speaker again
[Applause]